comment ça va ça va bien ça fait une
paye qu'on s'est pas vu dit d'en bas
depuis la dernière fois s'est pas trompé
c'est un peu comme dian tu dis la télé à
part alors à part mireille dumas et
drucker c'est tous des traîtres
alors merde
ben écoute en fait drucker c'est le sait
c'est quand même le sol le seul gars qui
a demandé à connaître mes musiciens tu
vois qu'il est sympa
il veut pas connaître quoi les briques
wavre n'en indique manon menace qu'il
n'a jamais su rebondir ouais bon oui
mais voilà toi tu les aimes bien
revanche drucker bah écoutes je ne
connais pas plus que ce à quoi devrait
aller en vrai c'est quand même le sol
mais kaka demandé à rencontrer mes
musiciens qui sont là ce soir d'ailleurs
je te remercie d avoir invité mercier
alors maso michel je connais michel
n'avait envie de fumer à un petit spliff
non je sais quoi non michel et sportif
je pense qu'on soit là dedans lui un bon
tu crois pas pense pas non c'est pas je
connais pas plus que cela et puis
mireille dumas c'est juste parce que je
la connais pas non plus j'ai jamais vu
mais c'est vrai quand je regarde la télé
bah c'est pas le top physiquement
je ne sais pas enfin tu la quittes quoi
tiers-monde je la kiffe ouais ouais
ouais c'est physique que ça arrive super
mireille way back truc ça s'explique pas
tu vois c'est quand même c'est comme ça
c'est d'amour et lara croft tu la
trouves comment par rapport à mireille
dumas je veux dire
ouais super moche ouais un gros thon
mireille est trop fort
[Musique]
c'est vrai
là
[Musique]
les mecs jurés ghislain truc c'est parce
qu'ils prennent mille sont toujours de
bonne humeur et voir si goldman et tina
loat clubs
invités mais pistolet en plateau man
ou woman show de
personnes
qui n'ont à ce qu il y en a qu'on
n'achète oui oui
so what they want them faut il parler
d'un jeu vidéo il fera 15 alors vous
sortez donc lundi un nouvel album qui
s'appelle je blesserai personnes diront
gym
karaté chine et en plus tu vois c'est
dans le premier single en duo avec le
toaster jamaïcain les fentes man
s'intitule scandale alors il ya elephant
man ya tiken jah fakoly en face et il ya
du monde à c'est un album qui a été
fabriqué la jamaïque ouais et vous dit
quand je suis arrivé le producteur clyde
en venait juste de prendre huit balles
dans le corps fait rare il a passé trois
semaines à l'hosto et quand il est
ressorti c'est pour venir en studio avec
moi exactement avec sa grosse serviette
sur le coup il m'a sorti une histoire
pas possible tu vois parce qu'en fait il
en a pris deux dans le nez comme ça de
l'aller face et puis une dans le bras et
35 dans le buffet la très mé les deux
qui sont qui sont qui sont rentrés dans
son nez en fait ils ont ricoché sur l'os
de son de sa peau mais hélas banjo mais
qu'at il dit
boulette et qu'en anonyme ça veut dire
les balles prennent des virages sur lui
qu as tu vois et en fait il s'en est
sorti il m'a rencontré un truc pas
possible il m'a dit que dans le corps on
a 20 circuits d'eau écoutant on avait un
circuit d'eau comme des durites avec de
l'eau dedans et il m'a dit t'inquiète
pas si tu vois giclée de l'eau à un
moment et en fait il avait une grosse
serviette dans sérieux dégâts à temps et
est donc un mauvais rebond chez ge et
paf trophée café touba un moment c'est
vrai dans le studio j'ai vu j'ai vu des
gros gicler d'eau ouais donc ils sont
sortis de son trou parce que les deux
balles sont sortis par le même trop
c'est de la bonne
kelly poudre
je n'allais pas dépaysés un benjamin hus
et les brutes à gori c'est bien jamais
la jamaïque ouais c'est un peu nuageux
quoi non franchement avec la franchement
à propos de la jamaïque donc tu vois moi
je suis très fidèle à la jamaïque parce
que la jamaïque finalement
ils m'ont jamais accueilli comme
personne tu vois et
pour eux je suis un chanteur de reggae
pierpoljak là bas j'ai tous les artistes
tout ça c'est pas pour faire le
prétentieux et tout ça mais je suis je
suis bien intégré dans la commune comme
adam au japon quoi comment adamo
ouais c'est vrai bah ouais bah peut-être
énorme star au japon mais moi je n'ai
pas une énorme star en jamaïque je
connais juste l'alimentation là bas je
connais juste non al hayat iliad et il
ya des soldats
voilà avant soldats là a
alors fait toi aussi tu vois tu ne sais
pas où tu apprends mais j'aimerais bien
goûté à l'or depuis le temps qu'on ment
pas j'aimerais bien goûté à ça doit être
sympa
là je le vois t'as pas fumer alors vous
allez découvrir là
vous avez découvert jamais qu'en prison
en fait quand vous avez passé six mois
floride tombé sur un guadeloupéen qui
vous a parlé des îles pendant des heures
et quand vous avez été libye non mais
c'est vrai que c'est vrai mais j'étais
gazier que ceux qui se disent oui c'est
vrai ben écoute c'est pas grave problème
ouais bah ouais super la prison c'est
comme l'hôpital bien sûr ruth et sociale
cds administration qui va tu vas pas
mais à quoi bon bref et ce guadeloupéen
tu as parlé pendant dix heures jean
pierre dulac issa voilà je peux je
n'oublierai jamais donc en fait tu vois
gtgc un petit des mains quand je suis
sorti de prison j'ai un vaguement
continuer ma petite délinquance un peu
minable on va dire et en fait finalement
j'ai réussi à avoir un peu de un petit
cache pour partir là bas et j'ai j'aime
la musique jamaïcaine en général tous
les artistes dont bob marley évidemment
c'est un peu le far du du reggae musique
mais bon il ya dennis brand
desmond dekker estime ce mythe enfin
pour ceux qui connaissent et c'est
ce qu'on va faire bien une interview et
pourquoi tu n'as charest pas large
explique roche a pas de temps mais
maintenant c'est à dire qu'après avis il
dit j'ai fait craie sur un côté des
grosses conneries ça c'est le moment là
c'est ta gueule
vas-y maialen des foules toi à faire une
interview comme bobby
pierpoljak est est ce que comme bob
marley vous fumez de l'abn ganja yes i
do when je fume de la bonne ganja un
essai comme bob marley vous kiffez le
football comme bob marley bas moins que
lui quand même pas lui qui fait beaucoup
il jouait il jouait beaucoup aussi quoi
moi
moi j'aime bien comme sport j'aime bien
faire du bateau ouais ouais c'est
différent est ce que bob marley vous
êtes né dans un ghetto j'ai grandi dans
des dans des quartiers un en banlieue
ouais enfin 91
92 93
est ce que comme bob marley fait fort en
soudure
alors pour pour bilop de spliff et
sfr là non bon je plaisante il n'y a pas
que ça dans la vie non plus je veux pas
passer non plus c'est vrai que je fume
de l'herbe et tout ça à bon ok tu peux
fumer du shit aussi tepa
est ce que bob marley vous diriez pas de
femme pas de pleurs pas de femme pas de
pleurs no
way doit
pas de femme pas de fleurs ouais je sais
pas larry 100 femmes c'est pas possible
de façon il ya toujours des pleurs de
ch
qu'elle aimait les
sommes payées un shoot again c'est clair
t'as je crois que la prochaine sortie
gratuite
maintenant votre main j'ai l'impression
dans la mecque et ouillage tu verras
remarque bien l affaire
de la catho
est ce que comme bob marley vous
pourriez shooter un shérif ne pas
l'adjoint ah ouais alors là ça c'est la
super bonne question
en fait il faut que je te parle d'un
truc et c'est en même temps c'est bien
que ce soit à la télé devant devant
beaucoup de beaucoup de gens qui sont
devant leur poste et tout ça je suis un
problème un jour jal en studio avec mon
fils aîné est un musicien jal en studio
studio de la scène
donc j'ai pris le métro qui sont
martyrisés mais tout ça je prends le
métro j'arrive à gare du nord je me fais
arrêter par des policiers
qui parle super mal est bon ça en deux
minutes je me fais casser la gueule
ainsi que ainsi que jimmy mon musicien
clavier quoi et donc on se fait casser
la gueule on se fait emmener au
commissariat on pas ce truc là la
journée au commissariat
et finalement on est accusé par les par
les flics de
de les avoir agressées et ils disent que
mon collègue a essayé de prendre le
son arme sur lui et donc finalement on
avait pris un avocat ggg porté plainte à
l'hygiène gt3 fois les gs et gégé donc
j'ai vu là-bas une femme qui pour une
fois parce que je trouve pas du tout la
police de toute façon mais j'ai vu cette
femme en qui j'ai eu un peu confiance
après on a été trois fois il ya une
confrontation donc avec les trois
policiers qui ont fait des fausses
dépositions
ont menti complètement contre le celui
en question c'est un champion dit le
gars c'est un jeune gars c'est un
champion de lutte donc il nous a écrasé
le coup nous a mis par terre ils ont
tapé les menottes enfin le truc régulier
quoi devant tout le monde qui qui
passait dans le couloir et c'est très
dur c'est très dur de se défendre ça
fait cinq fois que le jugement il est
reporté on est super innocent tu vois et
elle le sait probablement très bien
aussi elle m'a dit textuellement que de
toute façon les flics ne pouvait pas
être inquiété dans une première affaire
il fallait qu'ils en aient encore une
autre de dents pour qu'on commence à
s'interroger sur leur cas parce que
franchement là il ya un manque de
respect il ya tu vas du piétine âge du
duvet dire moi ça fait longtemps que
j'ai pas eu de cession quand on remonte
dans mon nom mairie cordes longtemps
quand j'avais 15 ans tout ça on peut
trouver des trucs mais ça fait longtemps
machin musicien et je suis pas là dedans
en plus j'avais j'avais pas de broc sur
moi j'avais mon titre de transport je me
suis fait casser la gueule et j'aimerais
bien que tout le monde le sache quoi
pourtant je suis je suis je suis je suis
pas violent comme gage suis je suis je
suis je suis plutôt du côté amour et
tout ça tu vois et unité un mais
mais la vie est ainsi faite quoi tu vois
tu peux pas je peux pas moi je peux pas
être un agneau non plus et bellay tu vas
la joue gauche quand on tape la joue
droite non non pas du tout non parce que
je vois pas pourquoi on me taperais la
joue gauche
alors que j'ai rien fait tu vois déjà
commencer quoi est ce que comme bob
marley vous croyez que vous pouvez
changer le monde pas du tout pas du tout
mais lui l'a par contre lui bob marley
leu leu
le truc qui dépasse le le chanteur de
reggae c'est qu'il a il a influé sur la
conscience des gens quand il l'a fait il
a fait du travail dans les cerveaux des
des gens de tous les pays quoi notamment
des pays du tiers-monde et les autres
aussi d'ailleurs est ce que comme bob
marley vous pourriez mourir jeune pour
devenir culte
ben moi je suis déjà mieux donc
seul
mon frère
de trois quarts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi
d'accord
vous devez choisir un invité et
l'embrassé
[Rires]
vous pouvez m'embrasser vous
faye je laisserai personne
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu